three months after the 2020 election the
libs published an article in time
magazine explaining how they rigged it
the secret history of the shadow
campaign that saved the 2020 election
in a way time magazine wrote trump was
right there was a conspiracy unfolding
behind the scenes one that both
curtailed the protests and coordinated
the resistance from ceos both surprises
were the result of an informal alliance
between left-wing activists and business
titans their work touched every aspect
of the election they got states to
change voting systems and laws and
helped secure hundreds of millions in
public and private funding they fended
off voter suppression lawsuits recruited
armies of poll workers and got millions
of people to vote by mail for the first
time they successfully pressured social
media companies to take a harder line
against disinformation and use
data-driven strategies to fight viral
smears this piece is thousands of words
long it's worth reading all of them but
the short version is that the libs
rigged the election now of course you're
not allowed to say that
if you say that you will be called a
conspiracy theorist and a kook and an
election denier and an insurrectionist
but they're allowed to say it
they boast about it in what mike anton
calls the celebration parallax
when the libs talk about rigging the
2020 election it's a wonderful thing to
be celebrated look guys we did it look
how we did it when conservatives repeat
the lib's own words back to them it
becomes a dangerous conspiracy theory
and a threat to democracy
but they did rig the election
and they're doing it again
and this time they're not waiting until
three months after they do it to admit
that they did it they're admitting it
right now
and they don't need thousands of words
to admit it in fact they barely used any
words as you can see from the search
warrant affidavit that biden's doj used
to justify the raid on president trump's
mar-a-lago home just black black black
all redacted text there must be some
really powerful stuff in here to justify
such an unprecedented attack on a former
president and current chief political
rival
but i can't know that for sure
because all of the crucial information
in the affidavit is redacted there are
so many blank pages in this affidavit
i'm thinking of suing for plagiarism on
top of the stonewalling they released
the affidavit on friday because as with
all friday news dumps they hoped to kill
the story over the weekend and start
again with some news stories on monday
but this story is ongoing and it's going
to keep on going until election day 2024
and the story is simple as can be the
entrenched powers are going to do every
single thing that they can
norms and procedures and rule of law be
damned to rig the 2024 election and
ensure that the people don't have the
chance to send donald trump back to the
white house i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from someday glory
who says this is this is how the
conversation went between the fbi and
facebook hey mark can you help us hurt
trump uh yeah
you're gonna say anything if we spy
using our software do we get a copy of
course then no that's probably how it
actually went that's probably true i
think that version is a lot closer to
the truth than anything we're being told
certainly by the fbi and the doj really
by any of the established powers we need
to hire better people to run our
government when you want to hire better
people i strongly recommend you check
out
ziprecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles hiring is challenging especially
right now when you've got so much on
your plate luckily there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place where growing businesses
connect with qualified candidates that
place is ziprecruiter.com
knowles ziprecruiter uses its powerful
matching technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
you can easily review those recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day that's why zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site based on g2 satisfaction ratings as
of january 1st 2022. right now you can
try zip recruiter for free
our listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s just like beyonce zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
they're doing it they're rigging the
election they're rigging the 2024
election in real time and they're not
even trying to conceal it well they're
they're concealing it in the sense that
they're concealing almost this entire
effort david just look at all this all
this black text everything's just
blacked out
but other
after knocking down trump's door at
mar-a-lago and after investigating his
businesses for
tax fraud or whatever now they're also
just calling to indict him so the new
york times editorial board has this
piece uh just ran august 26th
donald trump is not above the law
and they talk about how
the trump's unprecedented assault on the
integrity of american democracy requires
a criminal investigation
and then they need to indict trump and
then they need to just do anything they
can
to stop this guy from running for
president now
they can do whatever they want they can
kick down his door they can take all of
his papers they can arrest his campaign
staff they can arrest him they can put
him in prison
donald trump is going to run for
president barring some unforeseen
health problem you know unless he gets
clinton or something like that sorry
unless he you know falls into a
depression and commits suicide god
forbid
the guy is going to run he's telling
everyone around him that he's 200 going
to run for president and they can't stop
him whether they use the presidential
records act or the espionage act or
whatever other nonsense they're trying
to bring up whether they throw him in
jail the guy can still run let's not
forget the 1920 presidential election
eugene debs who is the most prominent
socialist in america was arrested by his
political rival eugene debs obviously
had never been a president himself but
he was running as a socialist even from
prison he got seven percent of the vote
about 6.8 percent i think it was donald
trump obviously would get a much higher
percentage of the vote so he'll run he's
going to run i think from pretty much
anywhere and that's what's driving the
libs nuts and that's why they're
throwing spaghetti at the wall had
donald trump
not intimated that he was going to run
again i think they would let the guy
sail off into the sunset someone pointed
out yesterday some blue check on twitter
said gosh can you believe it donald
trump he's under investigation for tax
fraud and for
classified document possession and for
this that and the other thing he said
can you and
he's the republican frontrunner in 2024
right i think maybe you've got it
backwards why do you think he's under
investigation for all those things
because the because the fbi and the doj
regularly prosecute cases of
ex-presidents having classified
documents no of course not
they think they don't go after obama for
that i know they didn't go after clinton
for that kind of stuff bill clinton
stole not just documents he stole the
furniture out of the white house they
went after him i don't think so they
ain't go after lbj they can go after
richard nixon on that for goodness sakes
no they don't they're just throwing
spaghetti at the wall because he is the
republican front runner and they don't
want him to be the guy
federal law enforcement right now is
being used as the private police for the
democrats the fbi is basically admitting
that so after mark zuckerberg shows up
on joe rogan's show and he says hey
don't blame us for censoring trump don't
play don't blame us for censoring the
hunter biden laptop story we got a call
from the fbi and we just went along with
it
after that the fbi had to respond it was
such an explosive allegation here's the
response
the fbi routinely notifies u.s private
sector entities including social media
providers of potential threat
information so that they can decide how
to better defend against threats and the
fbi cannot ask or direct companies to
take action on information received we
just kind of you know we just kind of
let them know so this is an admission of
guilt
if the fbi did not pressure facebook to
censor the 100 biden laptop story they
would have just said it said we never
told facebook about this we never told
facebook to suppress this thing but
instead they're saying look okay look
sometimes we call up social media
companies
we say hey
hey we sure wouldn't like the story to
get out there
hey that's a nice big tech platform you
got there she would be ashamed if
something happened to it sure would be a
shame if you got prosecuted wouldn't it
be so anyway maybe let's suppress this
little story over here and that's
obviously what happened and this was
particularly significant because after
the 2020 election
you had according to one survey 17
of biden voters who said that had they
known about the hunter biden laptop
story they wouldn't have voted for biden
which certainly would have swung the
election to donald trump unless you had
a lot more
a lot more shenanigans in the weeks that
it took to count the ballots unless you
had a lot more shenanigans than say
pennsylvania where they just sent out
widespread mailings in violation of
state the state constitution even with
all of that if you swing 17 of biden
voters to trump i don't see how they
could even pretend that joe biden won
the election so facebook did that
and what we're now learning is actually
the fbi did that
they did that in 2020. you don't think
they're going to do that in 2024 they
already are
they're kicking down the guy's door of
course they're going to do that
and it's not because they're even after
trump it's not because of that trump is
so special
you know they're all pretending that
trump is hitler or something like that
let's not forget until trump started
running in 2015 donald trump was one of
the most beloved cultural figures in
america everyone got a kick out of trump
he had the most popular show on nbc he
had he was in hundreds of rap songs
the republicans kind of got a kick out
of him the democrats got a kick
everybody liked the guy he was a popular
celebrity kind of helped out new york
fix that ice skating rink
and then he runs for office as a
republican and he actually does things
that conservatives want him to do he's
really the first president of my
lifetime to make a conscious effort to
do what the conservative base wants him
to do not just the chamber of commerce
and what happens they call him hitler
and they say we've got to change all the
rules and the and we've got to act in a
lawless manner to stop him from running
for president again and according to joe
biden by the way
the the
americans who voted for him you know
virtually the entire republican party
they're the fringe they're the radicals
according to joe biden
it's the the never trump republicans
which makes up i think about seven
people at this point the never trump
republicans they're the mainstream he
biden just tweeted out in this moment
those who love this country democrats
independents and mainstream republicans
must be stronger more determined and
more committed to saving america than
mega republicans are to destroying
america
percentage of the republican party is
never trump
the most
generous
wild statistics on this would say about
six percent or so
94 percent of republicans support trump
at least and really i bet the number is
even higher than that
and yet according to biden that that six
percent tops that's the mainstream the
rest of you virtually half the country
they're the fringe we i'm sorry we're
the fringe we're the radicals we have
we're trying to destroy america half
this country according to biden
and we've got to essentially be kept out
of the electoral system deplatformed on
social media have our votes suppressed
not be able to express our views
have our have our candidate
locked up for whatever reason to save to
lock up half the country to save
democracy does that make sense to you
doesn't make sense to me gets me
thinking that i really need to get my
energy up for a tough political fight
when i want to really just feel good get
my energy up you know i gotta check out
good ranchers right now head on over to
goodranchers.com
knowles regardless of what joe biden
wants to call a recession americans are
worried food and gas prices are higher
than i've ever seen in my lifetime we're
talking about 40 or high really all-time
highs i guess that's why i'm so very
grateful for my favorite meat delivery
service good ranchers good ranchers
offers an inflation-proof subscription
model that lets you lock in the price
the day you subscribe i'm not joking or
exaggerating even with all the crazy
inflation that we're seeing you
subscribe right now you can always buy
good ranchers just a one-off box of meat
but if you subscribe
the price will never go up for the cost
of your subscription also you can pause
your subscription for up to 90 days
cancel anytime you want but you're not
going to want to not only that good
ranchers is also currently running a
back to school give back program with
the goal of donating 100 000
high-quality meals to children in need
to help them i'm offering 10 lucky
listeners the chance to win 30 minutes
with me via zoom on september 30th we're
calling it a meet and greet do you get
it you can ask me anything on the call
be a lot of fun head on over to
goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles at checkout you get 30 bucks off
plus free shipping subscribe to lock in
your price recession proof your meals
for life be automatically entered to win
30 minutes of all access with me on
september 30th that offer ends august
31st goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles at checkout
according to
the white house
i'm not saying the fringe people on
msnbc or cnn or the crazy blue checks
i'm saying according to the white house
ordinary conservatives
are fascists a threat to democracy
trying to destroy democracy the actual
mainstream of the republican party 95 of
the republican party we are fascists
according to
the white house
only semi-fascism come in yeah is this
something we're going to hear more of
that phrase is it something the
president's going to kind of embrace or
is there any sense that it was uh you
know a little impromptu and it's gonna
turn into a kind of basket of
deplorables thing that he regrets and
tries to be quiet about
look i was very clear when uh when
laying out uh and defining uh what uh
you know mega republicans have done and
you look at the definition of fascism
and you think about what they're doing
in attacking our democracy what they're
doing and taking away
our freedoms uh taking away wanting to
take away our rights our voting rights i
mean
that is what that is it is very clear
and that's why he made that um that
that powerful speech that you heard from
him last night and he has not shied away
from saying that
if you look at the definition of fascism
i would be willing to bet
my entire life savings i would be
willing to bet all the rights to my to
my book with words to my book without
words i would i would be willing to bet
all of every single dollar that i ever
will make
that karine jean-pierre
white house press secretary
has never even heard of
much less read
the doctrine of fascism the the essay by
mussolini invents fascism for all
intents and purposes the essay by
mussolini and the italian philosopher
giovanni gentile that defines fascism
the doctrine
of fascism i guarantee you
she is she has never even heard of it
i promise you that karine jean-pierre
and all of the libs who fling this word
fascism around have never read i don't
know felipe marinetti who was the
founder of futurism interestingly and
then
becomes one of the founders of fascism
writes an early fascist kind of
constitution
it's uh
it was an er an early kind of
constitution of of the italian foshi of
of combat i guarantee it's the it was
one of the early manifestos i guarantee
you that she's never even heard of the
thing or any of those people involved i
because for the libs
fascism just means something i don't
like
now fascism has a meaning fascism was an
actual discreet political movement that
comes out of italy i i happen to have
read a fair bit about fascism just just
by happenstance my majors in college
were history and italian so if you don't
read if you if you don't read a thing or
two about fascism you've probably missed
a fair bit of the
of the uh last hundred years of italian
history 100 340 years of italian history
but it's a real thing
okay and
it's lost its meaning
it is now i think orwell pointed out too
all it really means is something that i
do not prefer
the the
purpose of using this language fascism
is not to refer to anything that the
republicans are actually doing we're not
i mean there's it is very very silly to
compare american conservatives in the
year of our lord 2022 to fascists it's
just it you have to be
totally ignorant to do that but the the
political effect of this the reason that
they're using this kind of rhetoric is
because fascism one is elided with
nazism in the modern imagination even
though those two movements are very
different movements but
they they blur the two and it's a way of
saying
that my opponents
are the incarnation of evil because in
the modern conception the fascists are
the absolute perfect 100 incarnation of
evil and so they have no rights
whatsoever
they need to be exterminated they need
to be kicked out of the body politic
ostracized at best they need violence to
be inflicted upon them they are
completely delegitimized
that's what that means and that's what
the white house is saying that's why
they're using that term they're not
using the term because it's precise
they're not using the term because they
know what it means they don't they're
just using the term to say my political
opponents the republicans they're not
mainstream even though they're half the
country and they need to be ostracized
suppressed pushed to the fringes and
exterminated that's what they're saying
do you remember there was some kind of
uh
white supremacist type a few years ago
richard spencer who was out he was i
don't know he was talking on a street
corner or something and a guy walks up
and just clocks and punches him right in
the face
and usually no matter what's what
someone's opinion in america if they're
peacefully expressing their opinion
we're all supposed to say okay no
political violence that's really not
acceptable and you remember when richard
spencer got punched in the face
all of the mainstream journalists
laughed about it they joked about it
jake tapper posted a comic of captain
america he said oh well that's what
happens we we punch fascists in the face
it doesn't matter how odious you find
richard spencer or his views
what you're seeing is
a mainstreaming of political violence
and by the way the libs see absolutely
no difference
between
richard spencer or whoever some kind of
more fringy political character and
donald trump and the average trump voter
and ordinary mainstream republicans they
see no difference and they are
implicitly sometimes explicitly calling
for political violence on all of them
and it's happening i'm not being
hyperbolic a lib tried to assassinate
brett kavanaugh at his home
like a month and a half ago okay you had
mainstream republicans for the past
mainstream democrats rather for the past
three or four years maxine waters
hillary clinton all the rest calling for
violence calling for people to push back
quote unquote on republicans mainstream
elected and appointed republicans in
public spaces to not be civil with them
hillary clinton's words to go to their
homes maxine that's what maxine waters
was calling for eric holder calling for
this kind of stuff
all sorts of this is becoming mainstream
we're we're still two years out
we're not even two years out yet from
the presidential election
things are going to accelerate very very
quickly and even with all of that
even with all the constant haranguing
and being told we're
we're fascists and all the rest the gop
is still absolutely crushing it on the
generic
ballot so
before midterm elections you have the
generic congressional ballot it's not
measuring the actual candidates who are
running in the different counties and
different districts rather but it's just
measuring republican versus democrat
it's usually a pretty good indicator of
how the parties are going to do in the
midterms a generic republican candidate
is now holding a five-point lead
over the generic democrat that according
to rasmussen
uh the midterm elections are 74 days
away
the most recent report showed that
republicans are leading 47 to 42. now
this is down a little bit from july july
the republicans had a 10 point advantage
which is just insane that's a ridiculous
advantage on the generic ballot
but the five point lead is great and the
drop has stopped so it went ten nine
eight seven six five but it's maintained
five now for some time and also by the
way
when democrats took the house for the
first time in eight years back in 2018
they had a five-point advantage
okay and by the way they had a
five-point advantage at this time in
that cycle their advantage actually
narrowed going into november and they
still retook the house so the
republicans are sitting pretty right now
it's hard to imagine short of some kind
of crazy shenanigans in the election
that republicans don't retake the house
will they retake the senate it's a
tougher map it's kind of hard to know
but the momentum is clearly on the
republican side even with all the
threats all the all the risk of violence
from the libs even with the fbi kicking
down the door and the social media
companies clamping down people
realize that our democrat-led
ruling class is really corrupt and not
doing very well for the country we are
in i think a period
of renewal
and you're seeing this not just at the
political level though the political
level is a representation of this
but at a cultural level and ultimately
at a religious level
you're seeing this oh my gosh eminem
i don't really like eminem i don't
really listen to rap music generally
eminem just comes out
and
posts a christian rap song
over kanye west you know kanye west has
had this very prominent kind of
reversion or conversion to christianity
well eminem who's a way more lib kind of
angry type rapper he's just come out and
wrapped the lines quote today's the day
i put all of my trust and faith in you
father please let this hate make me
stronger for they turn on me like a
zombie it's like i'm being strangled
unconscious when temptation is almost
like satan is make making you trying to
take you away from your daughters he's
rapping about rectangular objects in the
end about about coffins about life and
death he's calling on his savior and
he's doing it over kanye's song we are
living in a period of renewal i'm going
to get to this full song in the member
block today every day we do something a
little different on the member block
sometimes we interview people sometimes
we go into music sometimes we go into
crazy woke ads that we'll react to we're
going to get into this song in the
member block today because i really want
to go over it lyric by lyric but this is
a period of renewal and it doesn't
always feel like we're living in a
period of great spiritual renewal but we
are it is happening right now you are
seeing it
whether you think it is
uh sincere or not whether you whether
you think there are some other
motivations here or not is simply
happening this
eminem song over this kanye west song is
a sign of the times
why is eminem
rapping about christianity all of a
sudden and doing so in a way that seems
to contradict some of his previous rap
why is it well there's two explanations
one the charitable view is that eminem
is really experiencing tough temptation
and he's realizing the
the shallowness of a life lived for
material pleasure and in this kind of
squishy secular awful ultimately satanic
kind of mindset and he's saying i want i
want something better i choose god okay
i reject all that temptation and i
choose god that's the charitable view
now let's say that that's not the case
let's say eminem this is all just kind
of a performance none of this is really
sincerely felt
at the very least
what it means is that eminem is looking
at the culture and saying the future of
this culture
is with god
the future of this culture is with
christianity
all that
just atheistic materialistic crap that's
old that's passe that's dated and if i
want to remain relevant in the culture
i'm going to do that look at kanye who's
who's the essentially the biggest pop
star in the world it's kanye west in
many many ways that guy is kind of the
future
you look at politics
and celebrity culture
who's the biggest celebrity in the world
the biggest celebrity world is in the
world is donald trump
and donald trump again i whatever he
sincerely believes i think he probably
has some sincere belief but whatever he
sincerely believes he talks a lot about
god he talks a lot about christianity he
talks a lot about rejecting our decadent
depraved atheistic crazy culture and and
pursuing a more traditional culture and
pursuing christianity ultimately
so you don't frankly to
to to be comforted by this to be
encouraged by this none of these people
even need to believe it sincerely the
very fact that they are observing the
culture and saying oh this is the future
god is the future which is
god is the past and the present the
future whether but the the
move toward god the acceptance of god
the this kind of spiritual reawakening
the fact that all of these pop culture
kings moguls celebrities the fact that
they see that is a very very encouraging
sign
there's a there's a
related story here that i want to get to
i meant to get to this last week there's
this uh heretical liberal jesuit priest
by the name of father james martin and
uh james martin he's he's a
spiritual type of advisor i think and at
least a friend to people like stephen
colbert joe biden the democrats those
kind of people and so the other day
a former archbishop named remember
weekland died at the age of 95. and
archbishop weakland was notorious he was
a really notorious figure in the
episcopacy this guy shredded copies of
the weekly reports detailing child
sexual abuse by priests uh weekland it
admitted this by the way in a 1993
deposition that he destroyed these
copies
he admitted that he was in a homosexual
relationship he was not celebrate he
broke his he broke his vows
he
he
pretended that he didn't think sexual
abuse of children was criminal he
actually said in his autobiography he
said quote we all considered sexual
abuse of minors as a moral evil but had
no understanding of its criminal nature
are you kidding me you don't need to get
a phd in criminology to know that it's
it's illegal to rape children are you
kidding me you never heard about this
anywhere it's just so brazen the
gaslighting from this guy
he it turned out he paid half a million
bucks almost 450 000 in hush money to
his former male lover so he embezzled
money from his from his diocese to pay
off his gay lover it was just you know
probably the sort of fella who ought to
repent and we should pray for him
obviously but he should go off into the
sunset pretty quietly and this priest
this liberal heretical jesuit priest
james martin father martin tweets out
archbishop remember weekland has died an
erudite scholar gifted pastor and
benedictine abbott primate
his legacy was marred by revelations
that he paid money to a man with whom he
had been in a relationship i considered
him a friend and mourn his loss may he
rest in peace
this is the compliment sandwich
this is he was a really great guy
and yeah he maybe he did some bad things
but i'm gonna really downplay those bad
things i'm gonna really downplay them
and he was a really good guy
that's that's the compliment sandwich
this reminds me of when that muslim
terrorist was assassinated by the us and
then the washington post called him an
austere religious scholar the guy was
the head of isis
an austere religious scholar has died i
don't think that's the defining feature
of this fella
why do i bring this up not even to talk
about archbishop weekland not even
really to talk about father james martin
just to point out
no young person listens to father james
martin or listens to him in a way that
is to you know edifying that sometimes
we will listen to him just to figure out
what the the kind of
unpleasant forces within working within
the church are talking about but we
don't we don't listen to him and say wow
that was so sanctifying why that was so
edifying that really taught me something
about myself the people who listened to
father james martin are
boomer lib secularists and lukewarm
people and squishes and stephen colbert
and joe biden
and
this is a really important fact because
while the libs and the squishes and the
lukewarm people have told us for years
that we need to destroy the liturgy and
water down christianity and stop
preaching the truth and go live on
everything and that's the only way we're
going to attract the youths back to
church it's the only way we're going to
win the youths over to our cause it's
just manifestly not true that's not what
young people want young people do not
want squishiness and worldliness and
lukewarmness young people want the truth
young people want clarity young people
want courage okay where these squishes
dominate where these where these
lukewarm people dominate
in when it comes to the church it's in
churches where the median age is about
92 and there are three people who show
up to mass when these squishes dominate
in the culture it is all just these kind
of aged hippies who never got over the
age of aquarius just bitterly hanging on
but the young people who actually have
vigor and energy and are willing to
retake the culture those people are on
the side of orthodoxy those people are
on the side of truth those people they
don't want to find some conciliation
on on
concepts that are totally opposed they
don't want to find a middle ground
between right and wrong and true and
false and good and evil okay
the young people who have
clarity and courage the young people who
are really fired up they're the ones who
are saying hey
this transgender stuff is insane men are
men and women are women
and the squishes and the lukewarm people
say well actually no look maybe okay
look here's what we'll do we're just
gonna we're just gonna chop off people's
genitals but only once they've turned 12
not when they're 11 okay we're going to
find a middle no you say there's no
middle ground boys can't be girls this
is extremely destructive nonsense just
cut it out that's what young people
want that is why
donald trump is the coolest thing to
happen to politics in our lifetimes
that's why he's got disproportionate
support among young people that is why
the democrat even forget about trump for
a second that is why the republican
party is filled with young vigorous
talent ron desantis he's a young man
he's vigorous he's popular
ted cruz ted cruz is 50 years old i'm a
little bit biased because i host a
podcast with him that podcast is one of
the most popular political podcasts in
the world it has a disproportionately
young audience why is that
because the guy is speaking courageously
because the guy just calls it like he
sees it
who are the other prominent politicians
on the republican side josh hawley super
young jd vance super young blake masters
super young marco rubio super young
there's i could go on and on
even nikki haley even tim scott even
some of the more moderate republicans
they're young they're vigorous when you
think of the democrats who do you think
of
joe biden nancy pelosi hillary clinton
all these people who are 150 years old
who just never got over the 1960s and
the 1970s
and who do they have absolutely no idea
what time it is speaking of the utes
horrible story about
we've talked about him on this show this
young boy
he's 10 years old and his pervert mother
calls him the youngest transgender model
in the world and he goes by the name
noella i don't know what his real name
is
so
the father of this boy has just come out
and and said a really heartbreaking
thing he said i have no say
in this child's life
so noella
whatever his real name is has a younger
brother named levi they were born to d
mccord
and timothy mccord
and then d and timothy divorced
and d
uh i guess became a lesbian or something
but now d and d's lesbian
partner they don't they identify as not
women or as men or i don't know they're
obviously very confused people and
they're forcing their sexual confusion
and perversions on this poor little kid
and now they're convincing the little
kid to be a girl and to strut around for
other perverts on the on the
on the red carpet
and this poor father has no say in in
his life he says i have no say in it
she's not my kid anymore this is really
interesting that even the father here is
buying into this transgender thing but
he's saying i don't i'll use the she and
i'm trying but i don't
but i just want to have some maybe not
he shouldn't be modeling or she
shouldn't be modeling or whatever
now
it's very difficult to know what
happened in this breakup
the the woman is alleging some kind of
abuse but again this woman is a complete
lunatic so i don't believe a word that
she says
and
what the father says is i was given the
opportunity to step back and let dee's
partner adopt the kids and i did that in
the hopes that they would not have all
the stress that this is causing in their
lives but obviously it's causing a whole
lot more stress because of these people
now raising this poor kid the issue here
is not men's rights or fathers rights
the issue is not even transgenderism
that's a kind of symptom of this the
issue is
divorce the fact that a divorce could
happen
is the cause of all of these problems
the fact that we have a no fault divorce
culture here
and have for 50 years although in new
york they didn't have no fault divorce
on the books until about 10 or 13 years
ago
but that's what's causing this the
problems run so much deeper they've been
building for so long
and now we see the extreme expression of
it in a 10 year old strutting down in
stiletto heels you know for twerking
around for perverts
but
the the
earliest
manifestation of this began in the 1960s
and the 1970s and some people still
haven't woken up out of the age of
aquarius but
the young people the the people who are
fired up they have and they realize the
problems are not just going to be fixed
by having some conciliation with
transgenderism we've got to rip this
stuff out root and branch are you still
giving your money to woke razor
companies that hate your guts that see
masculinity as toxic and that think you
should teach your daughter to shave her
beard well there is a better way do you
know what the better way is
jeremy's razors they are 100 real
they're 100 woke free they're 100
fabulous the premium matt tungsten
handle has more heft than the left the
razor head pivots without caving has six
blades that are sharper than truth
when you buy jeremy's razors you aren't
just making jeremy richer you're making
the whole woke left poorer and that's it
you know for me if it were just making
jeremy richer i'd be i kind of take it
or leave it but the fact that i can
shave and with every stroke be just very
vindictive and impoverish the left that
makes me very eager to do so 75 000
people have already made the switch go
to jeremy's razors dot com to get your
founders series shave kit today jeremy's
razors.com jeremy's razors shut up and
shave
speaking of the kids
horrifying scene from a charlotte
pride parade you know the pride parades
they're family-friendly events they're
really wonderful they deserve our public
funding they need space in public square
because it's all about love love is love
and acceptance and they're really really
great right except we all know that none
of that is true and we have video
evidence of it there's a poor little kid
who was brought up onto a stripper pole
with some half-naked i think woman
and and he was riding on her bare
midriff and lower parts and she was kind
of shaking on the pole showing this poor
little kid how to strut for all of the
other perverts in the audience
this wasn't even really the craziest
thing at this pride parade there's a
video of of all of these
i think i think a number of them are
women just jiggling and they're all
not half naked they're all probably 95
naked take a look
[Music]
this is what we're being told is family
friendly and it's just
a sex show that's all it all it really
is and that's all really that it has
ever been
i i'm reminded of a line from jason
whitlock you know jason whitlock over at
the blaze i loved this line i was on a
show with him one time i wish i had the
clip
we're talk about marriage
and what to do about marriage and jason
whitlock was explaining why redefining
marriage is such a dumb idea and i think
this this advice applies to the pride
parades and all the rest of it he said
you know
not everything is for everyone
when i was a young man i was a little
more promiscuous and my friends and i
would go to strip clubs
i didn't get married
because that wasn't for me because if
you the kind of guy who's going to strip
clubs you can't simultaneously be the
guy that's getting married not
everything
is for everyone
and that's true
that's such a good point a lot of wisdom
there from jason whitlock
pride parades
are not for children
obviously they're filled with leather
daddies and all sorts of sexually
deviant people performing sexually
deviant acts in public those are
obviously not for kids and if you talk
to any of the people who aren't so
twisted in their head who aren't
completely lost and you said hey do you
think a 10 year old should be at this
thing they would probably admit no it's
probably not really appropriate
but
we cannot in public life we cannot
simply tolerate things this is one of
the
this is one of the weaknesses of of
liberalism the modern kind and the
classical kind one of the weaknesses of
liberalism is that it pretends that the
public square is neutral and we can all
just tolerate everything and it won't
affect our public life and that's not
true
people have noticed that we've gone from
moral or program for the weird sex stuff
to then for about five minutes we
tolerated it and then instantly it
became mandatory celebration it's not
just hey tolerate me hey include me now
it's you have to celebrate me you have
to put the pride flag on your shirt you
need to put the special square on social
media you've got to actively celebrate
it
and
that's that's because that's how
politics works we have in order to have
a republic which republic comes from
race publica
the stuff we've got in common then we've
got to have those things in common and
we've got to have sacred
[Music]
sacred
things in common we've got to exalt
certain things we've got to cast down
other things we have to have taboos
taboos that are very high taboos are
very low and disgusting and we we have
to
we have to come to some agreement on
that
the pride parades are sick and
disturbing and they should be illegal
everywhere
and because there's no way to have the
pride parade on main street and say that
the kids aren't allowed to come because
when you do that then you're admitting
that they're obscene and perverted and
when you admit that then
then
you've undercut your argument for having
them on main street right in the public
square
so we've got there's not going to be
some squishy weak lukewarm middle ground
here okay and when you talk to the young
people i can't i talked to a member of
congress not all that long ago
i couldn't believe how deluded he was on
this question he said you know i've
always
he's a very good member of congress i
really like the guy but he said you know
i just assume young people are kind of
more libertarian that's what i assume
i don't think that's true the young
people that i talk to are way more
hardcore they have way more moral
clarity and way more courage than
the kind of boomer conservatives who are
largely just about cut my taxes and
leave me alone
because they see it because they realize
the consequences of it and we didn't
have to deal with the immediate
consequences during the age of aquarius
we certainly do now speaking of public
celebrations drew barrymore really
stepped in it oh yes she did drew
barrymore
beloved
film and tv star very well i don't know
anyone who doesn't like drew barrymore
she just posted a tick tock of herself
frolicking in the rain
and a
black identity activist got very very
upset by it
you and i both know
that you are capable of enjoying the
rain
and frolicking freely without filming it
and then posting it to tick tock
now you've just cosigned
okay you just co-signed at least 3
million 8.5 by 11 front and back
people who just
go out of their way
to disrespect and dismiss the boundaries
that black creators have set
and now you're one of those people
so
i guess my question would be
why
why why is it so important to all of you
to treat us like
we don't matter
yeah drew yeah drew barrymore
why why did you have to be so mean to
black people by
frolicking in the rain
when i first saw this clip i thought it
had to be satire maybe it is but i don't
think it is
she's
and the woman isn't making any argument
as i was trying i listened to i've
listened to it multiple times now i
don't hear any argument i hear words
that are being said in succession but i
don't see any of them forming a coherent
english sentence and but it she's got
the tone of an argument
be like saying
pineapple microphone
pineapple give it a google d
gobbledy
glass glass
wood
up down green
purple
hammer
right it's i've got the tone and the
inflection of an argument but i'm just
saying gibberish that's what that woman
is doing because
it's really representative actually how
the left is conducting politics because
they're not making arguments that that
refer to
the real meaning of words that use words
in the correct way that's what you hear
when carine jean-pierre calls everyone
fascists but can't point to any
definition of fascism that's what you
see with political correctness when the
word when the libs just change the
meaning of all the words sometimes
multiple times in a single sentence
because it's not about any logical
argument
it's all just about power
that video what that comes down to is
white people bad
black people good
white people do what black people tell
white people to do that's all that
really means if if you can pretend that
frolicking in the rain is a race issue
and that you have the right because of
your race to tell someone else because
of her race not to frolic in the rain
then all you're saying is
you you as a result of your race need to
be subservient to me as a result of my
race that's all that means
it's about power and that's what all of
this is about you're seeing a similar
argument from not just some kook on tick
tock but from some kook running for the
united states senate a
the democrat candidate for senate
wisconsin jesse mandela barnes
has just argued that national parks
are you guessed it racist quote
it's important to create more welcoming
spaces because things haven't always
felt welcome and that's historical just
that perspective given the fact that
national parks weren't made for the
enjoyment of people who weren't white
national parks are built on land that
was indigenous
things were bad things were terrible the
founding of this nation awful he says
but you know we are here now and we
should commit ourselves to to do
everything we can to repair the harm
because it still exists and it's
colonization and slavery
so there the
the claim he's making is right there in
the middle he says the the founding of
this nation awful
and the proof of this is that racism is
everywhere and you can't see it
it's in the parks okay where is it can
you point to that in history can you
point to that right now in the parks
do they have a whites only water
fountain in the parks no
but it's race it's it's it's all bad
america is all bad and then the language
we use for bad is race it's the worst
it's it's the worst thing you can
possibly be called in america is racist
so everything has to be tied back to it
even things that have absolutely nothing
to do with race like national parks and
frolicking in the rain but all that that
is about is power and its power aimed at
a very specific
uh
target namely the traditional american
political order
the founding of this country awful and
it's all awful and the word we're going
to give to what's awful about it is
racism even though things a lot of these
things have absolutely nothing to do
with race and that's our argument for
why everything needs to be overturned
all the traditions overturned and anyone
who defends the traditional american
order anyone who waves an american flag
i guess at this point mostly just
republicans they need to be
exterminated they need to be attacked in
their homes they need to be pushed back
on in public they need to be kept from
from exercising their free speech rights
they need to be kept from speaking the
public square and voting they need to be
ostracized and sometimes we need a
little violence to be inflicted on them
that is the argument from the libs right
now
the rest of the show is going to
continue you don't want to miss it it's
music monday baby we're going to be
listening to this new eminem song about
the gospel and taking some of your
questions and comments in the member
chat if you're not a member click the
link in the description to join us we'll
see you over there
[Music]
[Music]
you